he likes to pass the ball more when he
drives with his left
and i'd prefer him to pass than to shoot
or score
[Music]
what's up guys drew holder here i'm
gonna take you guys through my film
session the breakdown
uh just to show you guys what i do on a
day-to-day basis
against the best players in the world
and why i'm the best defender in the
league
let's go what's hard about steph is he's
super
quick he's really quick really shifty we
know how
he can get that shot off you so this a
game for me it
kind of becomes like a a long distance
track meet where
one of us are going to get tired and
it's not going to be me first
we already know that i'm staying with
steph no matter what i get hit by a
screen
fight through the screen over the top
underneath but most of the time over the
top because
i can stay closer to him and possibly
run him off the three-point line
at this point i'm just attached to him
i'm stronger than him so i feel like i
just try to be physical with them
and i don't want to give them any room
to be to get comfortable don't let him
just go whichever way he wants to go and
as they're doing that dribble handoff i
get my hand on the ball
there's also another term that we use is
called on an island so if i have steph
by myself and
he's in the corner and it's just me and
him
i'm on the island with steph and usually
when you're on that island
somebody from behind you has to
communicate and tell you like
what's going on so i crowd him because i
don't want him to shoot three i don't
want him to get any space
and then i kind of send them in one
direction you can see
my right foot is up at the top of that
three-point line and i'm kind of giving
them that baseline drive
knowing that my help is going to be
there and then being able to
just kind of reach in and knock that
ball out of bounds i didn't know the
exact
metrics but i also know for us to win
the game
he's gonna have to really fight that's
cool to
even just hear like being able to get
that on record
just like how much you pressure up on
somebody and these are professional
athletes and they're the best
to do it that's why they're in the nba
and they make this money dame
is called logo dame for a reason it's
not easy to guard somebody
up that high that's where i hear a lot
of my teammates and what's going on if
there's a screen which way to send them
i'm already picking them up close to
half court the screen comes up so they
communicate the screen
i get underneath the screen because the
big man
is up four five maybe even six feet
above
the three-point line which dame is
capable of shooting that
but i get underneath so that he doesn't
split he doesn't try to dribble back
and split between me and him
you see i kind of cut him off and then i
keep him
at that angle so that he has one way to
go i would prefer the ball
out of damien's hands and you see steph
dane trey young luca like lebron you see
these guys shooting from half course you
see a big shot like that go in
and that could really spark something in
in a score
defense is hard somebody like boston
where you have kimba who loves to shoot
the three but also can get to the basket
you have jason who's a really good
then they're a great one-on-one player
you have jalen brown
so all them i view them differently it's
corner field
and you're not supposed to leave corner
field or philosophy don't leave corner
field because that's one of the
best shots in the league i mean guys
make that with
with our eyes closed i ended up being
late to the closeout which
at this point i'm thinking i messed up
let me try to run him off the line
so i overshoot it and i try to get on
his left side to try to make him go down
the line
knowing that my help is there kemba to
go up against somebody like brooke who's
seven feet
that's going to be a difficult shot
jason i feel like i'm quicker than him
so i usually try to pressure up on him
for one he probably has
three or four inches on me he does a
nice like little crab dribble to a step
back
my momentum is forward i also know he's
gonna take this step back shot and i'm
gonna
just contest the best that i can that's
kind of where
my mind goes when i try to guard guys
who are
prolific scorers to know that like you
can pressure upon somebody and
still do a great job on them is y'all
just really making me feel good you know
like i'm out here i should be defensive
player of the year kids need to learn
defense man
it's fun kind of give you my insight on
defense and
and what it takes you got to start
locking people up man it's the way to go
get under their skin stop them
defensively man i love it